abone ol
[Müzik]
ama
ben de koşuyordu mezunuyum ve okuma
mümkün olduğunca geri dönmek
kaybettiğini aracılığıyla ben gerçekten
çok mutlu ediyor Ben tek konuşma
izlemeye gerçekten çok severim boş
zamanlarımda ve çoğundan da çok etkili
öğretilenler çıkanlarla ayrılırım O
yüzden kendi yaşantımdan olabildiğince
kısa bir sürede sizin hayatımızda en
kalıcı ne yapabilirim diye uzun düşündüm
Hatta Doğrusunu söylemek gerekirse son
zamanlarda hiçbir şey bu kadar fazla
kafa yorma Mıştım Benim En tutkulu ve
bilgi olarak yaptım şahsında gençleri
öğrencileri yaşça yakın olduğum
arkadaşlarıma Sen bölümlerini kaşık
etmektir Ve heyecanlandırmak thresh Hobi
olarak bu tarz içerikler paylaşırım ve
öğrenciler için sistem etkinliklerine
katıldı çok severim o yüzden dedim acaba
yaptığım işlerden mi bahsedeceğimiz
değilim tam olarak heyecan verici
buluşlardan ve araştırmalarda mı
bahsetsem acaba diye düşünür size kendi
uzmanlık anlamını çok dışında Hatta
akademik açıdan hiçbir bilgimiz bu Ama
yaşanmışlıklardan yola çıkarak
söyleyecek çok sözü ne oldu bir konuda
konuşmak istiyorum o da insan ilişkileri
Bir de sizden gelen biri olarak Ya zaten
normal doğrudan içinde alakalı olmayan
ve samimi bir konuşmak istedim ve
temayla bilgilendirerek ve mesafe ile
ilgili olsun İşte ben bu yüzden
hepimizin hayatlarına var olan ama çok
düşünmedin mi mesafeler üzerine
konuşacağım eğer bilim alanında Bu arada
kariyer ve eğitim odaklı sorularınız
varsa ve destek sayesinde bana bu konuda
benim konuşmadan sonra hiç çekinmeden
her zaman ulaşabilirsiniz ama şimdilik
diğer konuya atıyorum birazcık ne senin
sonrasında neler yaptım ve sonrasındaki
hayatım özet geçmek gerekirse 2016
yılında koşan mezun oldum üniversitede
Amerika'ya uzak Üniversitesi'ne gittim
mezun olduktan sonra da bostana taşını
farketmedik okulda bir ama çaylı
çalışmaya başladım Az önce bahsettiğimiz
gibi çeşitli gösterin teşhis
teknolojileri üzerine çalışır o en son
hocam de ku-1019 tabii ki teknoloji
üzerinde hayatında bir bilim insanı
olmak yanında ilerletmek istiyorum şu
anda Bu doğrultuda araştırmalarına
eğitime devam ediyorum gelecek yılda bir
yüksek saç bakımında başlamayı planlarım
mesafe kavramı sanki komiden itibaren
hayatımızı ihtilal etmiş gibi geliyor
ama mesafe yazsın hepimizin hayatında
her zaman vardı ve her mesafenin bizi
zorladığı bize bir şeyler kalktı
öğrettiği tanıtım noktalar hep olmuştu
komik Ben önceden hayatımıza girmiş
çıkmış insanlarla aramızda her zaman
fiziksel de duygusal mesafeler
bulunuyordu Benim için de hayatımın
mesafe dolu dönemi üniversitede
Amerika'ya gitmem başladım önce doğal
olarak ailemle aramıza giren mesafenin
farkına varmaya başladım Sonradan da
listemde çocukluk arkadaşlarımla
aramayacağım mesafenin kabul etmek
istemez Seniz de hiç öyle olmayacakmış
gibi gelse de size bir kahve ikili insan
ilişkilerinde değiştiriyor aranızda
yatılı okuyan larımız varsa bunu daha
erken yaşlanma yaşamaya başlamış
olabilirsiniz ailenizden ve çocukluk
arkadaşlarımızla fiziki bir okuyuşu
şimdiden takmış burada belki Eğer bu
mesafelerin şimdiden farkındaysanız
Aslında ben de çok şanslı çünkü mesafe
kavramının bilincine varmak hayatınızda
çok güzel bir ilişki katıyor ve birazdan
O işte geleceğim Biz hayatımızdaki
kişilerle olan mesafeleri kısa tutmak
için çoğunlukla Ha gayret gösterelim
Mesela bir arkadaşınla aranın açıldığını
düşünürsen ne yaparsın hemen bir mesaj
atar Arar Hadi gel oraya kapatalım
dersin ya da örneğin uzaktasın da
annenin ve akrabanın hasta olduğunu
öğrendim Eğer insanlar zamandan açan
ediyorsun Ne yaparsın gerekirse Uçar
gerekirse koşar annenin akrabalık için
şarkı yanına gidersin
aranızda kime o şifre indirip yanında
olabilmek ona yardımcı olabilmek onlara
dokunabilmek istersin Peki kendine en
son ne zaman sordum herhangi bir soru en
son Kendine zaman sordum Ben iyiyim Ne
kadar iyiyim şeye ihtiyacım var mı Ben
ne kadar benim kendimi aram açıldı mı
Eğer açıldığını fark ettiysen kendime
olan Yolları katetmek dağları mesafe
gece sıfıra indirmek için en son ne
zaman uğraştım Ben sana ne yaptım işte
kendimiz olan mesafe biz böyle de mesafe
kendimi pilavın içine böyle bir ilişki
çoğunlukla Gerekli özeni göstermediği mi
sapa üzerine tak tak kafa yormadı ımız
bir ilişki türü
sevdiklerimizle aramızdaki mesafeler den
başladım Sonra konu kendimiz al
ilişkimize getirdim Neden Çünkü insan
yalnız kalınca ancak kendi ile olan
mesafesinden sorgulamaya başlıyor
başkanı başkalarına olan mesafesi o anca
tavan yaptığında kendine da almaya
başlıyor genelleme yapmayın tabii ama
benim için böyle oldu hayatım ne zaman
mesafeler girdi ne zaman Amerikaya
gittim ver sevdiklerine Uzak kalmaya
başladım o zaman kendini tanımaya ve
kendimi dinlemeye başladım bu Tabii ki
bir günde olmadı uzun ve hala devam eden
bir süreç zor bir süreç ama bir
farkındalıkla başlıyor her şeyin olduğu
gibi Ve tabiki sizin kendinize olan
ilişkin bir keşfetmeniz için illaki
Okyanus açmanıza gerek yok hatta ayrı
yere bile çıkmam gerek yok Sadece
uzaklaşmak yanıt almak kendini tanıma
sürecine zorunlu hale getiriyor
size bu konuyu konuşmak istememin sebebi
de tam olarak bu sizi zorunda kalmadan
Ya okul bir iş yeni bir hayat kurmak
için uzaklara gitmek zorunda kalmadan
önce kendinize farklı bir diyalog
kurmaya kendinizi abla mesafe bizi
tanımıyor başlayabilirsiniz hatta çok
değil yerler
Bu bir parçası olan insanlara her zaman
mesafe uzakta olacağız bu mesafeler Biz
yaşadıkça bazen artacak bazen azalacak
bazen de değişecek ve senin mesafelere
karşı diyebileceğim hiçbir şey Alabildin
hiçbir önlem koyacağım hiçbir barikat
kalmayacak komikler zaten hepimizin
gördüğü gibi
ama sen kimin olan mesafeni her zaman
kontrol altında tutabilirsin kendim
kiminle olan mesafenin sadece kendi
çabanı yok edebilirsin sadece kendinden
özetlemek gerekirse mesafeler komikti
baya komik Siz hayatımızda hep var
olacak ve biz de hem kendimiz hem bu
sevdiklerimiz olan mesajınız istediğim
uzaklıkta yakınlıkta bir dengede tutmayı
öğrenmek zorunda olacağız insan yalnız
kalınca kendi ile konuşmak kendine soru
sorma kendini dinlemek zorunda kalıyor
Ama sen şimdi ben kendimi bu diyalogları
başlatarak kendin ilk yardım çantası
olmayı öğrenebilirsiniz
kendine alan ve Ya ben Evlenmeden zaten
Ve her şart altında en kısa tutmam
gereken mesafen daima en yakın kendini
al kendine sorular sor benim yardıma
insana zamanla 19 ihtiyacım var mı ya
açık açık sor kendine cevaplarını bekle
ve gerçekten dinlen kendine bir
başkasına hatta küçük bir çocuğa
göstereceğim Merhameti göster Yardıma
ihtiyacın olduğunda kendi yardımını
herkesten Önce konuşmayı öğren kontrol
altında tutup her şart altında En
yakınında tutabileceğim sana her şart
altında destek olabilecek tek ilişki
kendine alan ilişkin olacak başlı başına
çok güzel bir şey teşekkür ederim